hey what's your name guy what's your
name Joey Joey okay my name is Daisy
almost shield over here for your
protection there's more on the way first
units down well wetting themselves okay
this should be good
good night Lu just go with it we'll be
right there with you it's not like this
taking any crazy all right right
rest easy we're almost there
we had him pinned down but the target is
escaped he didn't escape he was
extracted well secure the area clean and
contain the situation it is getting
harder for this to go unnoticed
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be a new agents of shield season 3
video that clip at the beginning of this
is just the first couple minutes of the
episode just giving you an idea that
they're gonna be hunting down the new
Inhumans Coulson's team to try and help
them the government to try and lock them
up the thing that's missing from this is
Ward's team he's gonna be one of the big
bads not the big bad that's gonna be
lashed from the comics but Ward is gonna
be putting together a team of X Hydra
agents Hydra is still kind of a thing in
the Marvel Universe I mean we're
probably gonna see some form of them in
Captain America Civil War but word spent
all of season two saying I'm not Hydra
anymore but he's also not shield we also
get to see Daisy's new costume she's got
her new gauntlets she's probably gonna
be a little bit better with her powers
remember it's been a little bit of time
since the end of season two usually
they're pretty good about telling you
what the timeline is so it's either
gonna be like one month since the season
two finale or it's gonna be like three
months usually the Marvel Universe
between the TV show in the films each
year move in real time so like whenever
Captain America Civil War comes it'll be
like six months after today the new
inhuman she's trying to rescue in this
isn't someone straight out of the comics
I think it's an original creation of the
show but it looks like he has the power
to break down the molecular bonds
between metals so you can see how that
might come in handy
opening locked doors creating holes and
interesting places the special effects
look like they're pretty good Marvel
actually has access to the same type of
special effects that they use for movies
just because it's all Disney that's one
of the advantages of Marvel being at
Disney is they just have access to much
more technology it's just a little
cheaper for them to get it they don't
have to go out and build that technology
themselves but what's going on here this
first half of the season is that Coulson
is helping people and at the same time
building out his secret warriors team
that's who the caterpillars are and
that's actually something right out of
secret warriors in the comics
caterpillars turning into butterflies
you know obviously so as these people
acclimate to their powers they'll become
butterflies they'll become secret
warriors if you have read secret
warriors from the comics they're
actually changing quite a bit about that
they're just taking a lot of the ideas
from secret warriors they're not going
to be doing any specific plotline from
the comics so if you haven't read it
don't worry it is a lot of fun it
heavily features Daisy Johnson really
what's at stake the first half of the
season is the lives of all these new
Inhumans you have Coulson's team that's
trying to help them you have the
government that's trying to lock them up
you have Ward that's trying to corrupt
them
then you have lash who's trying to
cleanse them all lash on the TV show
will probably be the closest to his
comic book art which is actually pretty
simple he's a relatively new character
in the comics he shows up when all the
new Inhumans show up after the big
terrigen bomb goes off and just tries to
kill them all taking in the Terrigen
mists is a really big deal in the in
human society people have to be selected
for it you have to wait they're
candidates they have a very rigid caste
structure so lash gets super pissed when
all these fish oil pills start creating
new Inhumans like it's no big deal some
of you been asking me about the fish oil
pills too like how do they work like if
you're not an inhuman if you don't have
inhuman DNA and you take a fish oil pill
do you get turned to stoned like people
that touch the diviner that weren't
supposed to last season the diviner
itself was what was killing people not
the Terrigen crystal if you touched a
Terrigen crystal and you weren't inhuman
it just wouldn't do anything so
presumably when all these fish took this
in they filtered out whatever that
diviner additive stuff was in these
crystals so when people take the fish
oil pills if they're not inhuman nothing
ends up happening otherwise there'd be
reports of fish oil pills killing tens
of thousands of people all over the
place so it's like the dangerous part of
these crystals that ended up getting
turned into fish oil pills just got
filtered out somewhere along the way
there were a couple other things at the
end of the season that they tease that
we're gonna find out about in the first
couple episodes
the most interesting thing obviously is
what happened to Simmons but they might
actually hold off on that she probably
just got sucked into the obelisk
it'll probably spit her back out at some
point after some big WTF moment there's
a bunch new toys they were building like
the new bus and then there's agent May
agent May is like somewhere floating
around she might end up crossing paths
with Ward a lot they were teasing that
she might end up leaving the shield team
not the TV show just the team but I
think if the show took a while to get
going last season like if it took a
while to actually start going somewhere
I think they're actually starting from a
much stronger place right now I think
the secret Warriors vs. Inhumans
storyline is actually gonna be pretty
cool what I really want to find out
though is who is giving lash his orders
or is he just operating by himself let
me know in the comments what are you
most excited about for agents of shield
season 3 like seeing all the new
Inhumans the way they do the different
powers in the show just seeing Daisy
Johnson do crazy stuff or learning more
about how Marvel is gonna treat its
Inhumans a lot of the stuff they do on
the TV show won't show up in the movies
but it will
inform what's gonna be happening in the
movies so like the way they treat
Inhumans on the TV show is the same way
they're gonna be treating them in the
movies and everyone's asking about
people from the TV show showing up in
Captain America Civil War
maybe Coulson maybe Daisy Johnson I'm
not expecting Daisy but Jeff Loeb &
Clark Greg did tease that Coulson might
show up in Netflix's iron fist show the
thing about that is is that iron fist is
the last TV series before the defenders
team-up so wouldn't it be awesome if
Coulson was the one to put the defenders
together just in the way Nick Fury put
the Avengers together and in real life
Clark Greg's favorite Marvel character
is Danny Rand so it's just like please
do me a favor let me be in this TV
series cuz I'm a huge fan in real life
and it just happens to make sense that
Coulson would be the one to put this
team together that's another good
question let me know in the comments do
you want to see Coulson be the one to
put the defenders together and do you
want to see him show up in some of these
Netflix series I would be amazed if
anyone said no and just for fun
Supergirl
Melissa Benoist is actually on the same
studio a lot with the agents of shield
people so they did like that dubsmash
thing it got me thinking who would win
in a fight Daisy Johnson or Supergirl
just assume that their power levels are
where they're at right now on their TV
shows so like Supergirl has not been
using her powers for the last like 10
years or so since she was a little girl
and Daisy Johnson just learning how to
use her abilities she's still mastering
them so I think it'd actually be a
pretty even fight like Daisy could pluck
her right out of the air because her
powers give her a limited form of
tactical aneesa's but Supergirl is super
strong and super fast and she can shoot
energy beams out of her eyes so if Daisy
Johnson didn't pluck Supergirl out of
the air fast enough Supergirl could just
smash her face in so I think it's really
a question of reaction time if you're
confused about the way Daisy Johnson's
powers work - the way they've expressed
them on the show is kind of primitive
her powers go way beyond just shaking
things and making things move around
she actually has the power to manipulate
the fabric of the universe it's just
that she's not very good at using her
powers she's not that sophisticated with
them yet so I think if she gets better
you'll just see her using her powers and
cooler and cooler ways that would
actually be a really awesome promo for
CBS and ABC just have Supergirl and
quake punch it out just aired during
sweeps week really
heroes reborn starts tonight I'm going
to be doing a video for it so just come
back in a little bit I should on my
video posted later tonight while you
guys wait for that you can click here to
catch up on vixen from last night and
you can click here for all my other
agents of shield in Avengers videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you